How often should I get a PET scan down?
What's the best way to check for reoccurrence?
Well, I think the best way to check for reoccurrence is probably a PET scan.
And that would be the gold standard. The negative is that it's about two and a half times the radiation dose of a CT scan.
And a lot of radiation from a PET scan. So you don't want to do it very often.
It partly depends on the person I personally haven't had a scan down for.
When two years ago that I did my scan, I think it was two years in March that I did my scan.
And it was good except for some liver lesions.
And am I going to do another scan? Probably not. So that's just me. So that's just my choice.
So everybody's different. Everybody has different levels of anxiety.
Everybody has different levels of what they're going to do from a standards of care approach because of our makeup, because of who we are.
And because of our cancer with me.
It's an easy decision for me because there is nothing with standards of care offers for my cancer.
So I mean, statistically, I should have been dead a couple years ago.
You know, statistically, it's a seven percent five years survival rate. You know, I've had six and a half years now, I think.
So it's, it's, I'm not going to do another scan. You know, even if my symptoms get really bad, I'm from, I'm still not going to do a scan because nothing they can do for me.
So, but you know, you have other options with breast cancer. So maybe you would do another scan. And you might have different levels of, you know, anxiety that you're struggling with with things to get another scan can be helpful to relieve that anxiety.
So, you, is there damage that could occur because of the radiation of the scan? Sure. But you just got to weigh out what, you know, what's better for you emotionally to know that you're doing well or a deal with the radiation and detox that and support your body through that or to, to not.
Everybody's got to weigh that out.